[Music]
whether you play tactical shooters mobas
or even mmos each and every player to
ever touch an online video game has
complained about the same thing at one
point or another
ping
hello dude it's lagging out oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah we can't i mean we're done that's
it you thought siege was bad
in certain titles having a consistent
low ping is absolutely crucial
this is
there it is
this has to be live switch
this is awful
while in other games there are certain
activities or instances where you might
be able to get away with having a
slightly higher ping
so in this episode we want to figure out
just how important ping actually is is
having hai ping as bad as that dude who
just whiffed his shot makes it out to be
and is having really high ping
actually kind of a good thing
[Applause]
all right so before we dive into the
video let's see how fast you can like it
slap the subscribe button and turn on
notifications
just to test out your latency of course
so let's start with the easy question
what exactly is
ping
and now the guy who actually knows hey
whoa
not yet i got this all right geez
it's like they have zero faith in me i
know things well for starters it's not
just some random number that shows up on
the side of your scoreboard when you hit
tab in valorent
no ping is used to measure the latency
or amount of time it takes to send and
receive a packet of data between two
devices such as your computer and a
game's servers and most importantly ping
is measured in milliseconds
so if you're far away from the server
which will happen if you're say queueing
with your west coast friends or farming
freelo on the european cs go servers
then you'll see that little number
beside your name go up the lower the
ping or latency the faster the
information is received and having a
lower ping will give you a smoother and
more accurate gameplay experience which
is really important if you're trying to
be a sweaty little tryhard
80 milliseconds on the grand scheme of
things doesn't seem like a whole lot but
when it comes to you know like
uh like winning an uh aim duel
especially when you uh you're a little
better and like you know people are
hitting headshots and you're hitting
headshots uh you know every second every
millisecond counts in online shooters
things like player models maps and
textures are stored on your pc but if
you're competing against other players
online then only the basics need to be
sent back and forth between you and your
opponents this includes things like
bullet trajectory and updates to objects
on the map such as damaged buildings or
environments but if you are suffering
from high paying
then you might run into some issues
higher ping means that sending and
receiving information will take longer
bullets might not even register at all
and if the ping is too high then the
information can stop coming through
altogether which will cause severe lag
in extreme cases you might even
disconnect from the server
playing with really high ping is also
not a walk in the park it's really
annoying um the main things is it's
almost like everybody honestly sees you
before you see them a lot of times some
games will implement ways so that if you
have high ping it actually hurts you it
might feel like you're lagging
essentially you know i think we've all
been you know playing like cod back in
the day and you get that connection
error plug at the bottom of your screen
and everyone stops moving and is running
in place and it's just
so frustrating to deal with because you
know i mean you just want to play the
game normally and it feels like almost
as if you had if you ever had one of
those dreams where you're running but
you're not moving
yeah that is exactly like that playing
with high ping
in esports having low latency is
essential if you're playing a game
competitively then you need it to run as
smoothly as possible without any hiccups
and this is why every major event is
played on lan because when every player
is playing it sub one millisecond ping
then nobody has any excuses
if you miss your shot you kind of just
have to own up to it it is quite simply
the most competitive way to play
you never question yourself on lan it's
either did i miss or did i hit you know
what i mean it's it's essentially just
that you're either hitting the headshot
or you're hitting all your bullets or
you're not there's never a question like
oh like i feel like i shot before him or
i feel like i reacted faster but i ended
up losing so i just think lan is just
always going to be better but obviously
you just can't play on a land
environment regularly
so like fox just said not everyone has
access to lan servers each and every day
and when you're playing from home the
physical distance between you and the
game server is a huge factor when it
comes to determining your ping hell i
still can't get lower than 40 ping on
valerian because there just aren't any
servers near toronto let alone in canada
at all now there are factors other than
your ping to and from the server and
this is where we'll get into tick rates
but trust you don't want to hear me
complain about valve's
shitty 64 tick servers all day so here
is colton to help me out
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about presented by amd
you're right i don't want to listen to
you complain about valve servers but
thankfully we don't have to amd have
partnered with us once again to bring
you the most important segment on
cracked now players tend to associate a
game tick with a measure of time but it
actually describes a process with three
very important steps first a game server
will collect incoming player data and
events such as the location of a player
and bullet trajectory then the server
will perform calculations based on that
data and finally send the newly
calculated information back to the
players this ensures that all players
are seeing the same thing or as close to
it as possible and once the server has
done these three things it has completed
a single tick a tick rate refers to a
server's number of ticks per second or
more importantly for gamers the amount
of times per second that you're getting
new information from that server riot's
league of legends servers have a tick
rate of 30 which might come as a
surprise to many of you players have
noticed that the game's relatively low
tick rate causes certain abilities to
become somewhat unpredictable even at
the highest level i feel like a lot of
issues with league involve the tick rate
of like how the game updates it's like
every quarter second
and so it'll be really inconsistent with
like leblanc and
uh nocturne chain type abilities where
it's almost rng if you get out of it or
not based on like when the server takes
that yeah would make sense
i've noticed that right as well it's
like sometimes you flash out of the more
guilty and it tethers on to you
because it's like ticked at the wrong
time for you one of the most common
scenarios you'll encounter in league of
legends is getting hit by an ability
after you've already recalled since the
servers only send out updates 30 times
per second there are times where you're
already back in base but you still get
hit by an ability that your opponent
sent out just as you were recalling this
is because your opponent's information
was sent before the recall went through
but you didn't receive that information
until your recall animation had already
finished ping has actually been a
constant issue for high elo players in
north america since riot moved their
server from portland to chicago and from
the start some of them have been pretty
vocal about their concerns pro players
in nna have been forced to play on high
ping for years now and after constantly
getting smacked by teams on the
international stage a fix might finally
be on the way riot recently announced
that a new server named champions q will
allow na pros to compete against each
other with much lower latency something
that's actually already been in place in
other regions anyways back to tick rates
competitive shooters tend to need much
higher tick rate servers valve's cs go
servers for instance run at 64 ticks per
second and that's pretty solid but with
high refresh rate monitors becoming more
and more prevalent and players running
their game well over 200 frames per
second some games might still feel
somewhat choppy even on 64 tick rate say
you picked up a fancy new 144hz monitor
and your pc is pumping out 144 or more
frames per second but you're only
receiving updates from the game's server
64 times per second you might run into
some minor desync issues where the
simulation happening on your pc and
ultimately what you're seeing begins to
drift away from what's actually
happening on the server before that next
update gets pushed out luckily
counter-strike services like esea and
faceit have 128 tech servers to help
combat this issue and now with new games
like valrant becoming increasingly
popular 128 tick servers are the gold
standard valor and devs have even
managed to make the client side
simulation match the server side tick
rate regardless of what fps you're
getting and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
presented by amd a lot of you valerian
kitties can count yourselves lucky that
you will never know the struggle of
playing on 64 tick mm servers and trust
me once you go 128 you literally cannot
go back the difference is night and day
not to mention the fact that you have to
memorize different smokes for each tick
rate after playing on good crispy modern
servers anything else just feels
sluggish and gross it's kind of similar
to the feeling you get when you play on
a high refresh rate monitor and then go
back to 60hz it's a noticeable
difference and once you get used to
those crispy responsive clicks you're
not going to want to go back and
although they're still not perfect 128
tick servers are pretty much the best
thing that us normies are going to get
so baller has great head wedge like even
um yeah like sometimes it'll like feel
bs because it's not perfect it's not
1000 tick rate or something it's it's
gonna be every now and then it's gonna
feel weird it's not gonna feel like
uh perfect but it feels pretty close to
perfect
um even so much like you know my csgo
friends come over
and they'll be like wow like valor has
so much better hit range and i don't
think it's even the hit rich i think
it's just the tick rate at that point i
think balance just has a lot better
servers than valve's official ones
but with the release of valorant riot
also set out to eliminate something that
has plagued the tactical shooter genre
for many years so one thing that kind of
brings really clear to us on valerian
and into our designers is our philosophy
on competitive integrity so i guess in
essence right competitive integrity is
that for every single game you play
whether you win or you lose you're in
control of the outcome through no fault
of the other nine players or the game
server they will not hinder your
experience think of all the times you've
held an angle in any shooter and some
[ __ ] kid ferrari peeks you around a
corner and you get dumpstered before you
can even react that [ __ ] sucks
and what i am describing is referred to
as peeker's advantage peaker's advantage
has existed for as long as people have
been shooting each other online and
eliminating the issue is just not easy
for developers because the fact is it is
quite literally impossible for everyone
to have the exact same ping when there's
a large discrepancy in ping between two
players then it's a no-brainer that one
of them will likely see the other first
and despite riot's best efforts peaker's
advantage remains a thing in valorant
just like it remains a thing in every
other online shooter but once again the
reason is because they're playing online
and depending on your ping you might
even have to change your playstyle
playing on hyping is
obviously
really annoying i mean it's the same
with like csgo but
uh
you have incredible pickers advantage
um
but at the same time holding angles is
very very difficult on high paying
um but you know it's the same like for
if you're playing on high paying against
other people they're also are going to
struggle to hold angles against you
and you're gonna you know you're gonna
have a picker's advantage against them
opting in counter-strike for instance is
notoriously a big no-no on high ping
since the weapon is quite literally
designed to hold angles i'm assuming the
same is true of valorant since the
operator is even less mobile than the
sniper on which it was based so as
you've assuredly gathered by now a lan
environment is basically the only place
where you can accurately see player
movements as each competitor presses
their inputs
and this is because everyone has the
exact same sub 1 millisecond ping that
we all dream of but the problem nowadays
is that some not so nice players like to
use their high ping to their advantage
and that is called
ping abuse some players intentionally
queue on distant servers in order to
jack their ping up and create their own
peeker's advantage and let me tell you
playing against them kind of sucks
personally i've actually played against
a lot of people that ping abused right
now i'm playing against this one guy in
valor and almost every day who's from
russia and he's playing in north
american servers and it's just if he
swings you he pretty much has a whole
like two seconds of an advantage of
seeing you before you see him you're
pretty much getting
you know shot before you even see
anybody on your screen
now unfortunately these cowards aren't
just doing this in valorant you can
encounter ping abusers in pretty much
any online game and until we get to a
point where everyone has a sub one
millisecond ping or close to it then
peeker's advantage is to be expected so
does ping actually matter
of course it does
does it matter as much as the dude
bottom fragging on jet with 40 pings
says it does
probably not but ping always has and
always will have a huge influence on how
we play the games we love and although
you hear counter-strike stands like
dimitri complaining about peaker's
advantage all the time in almost every
situation playing on high ping just
isn't a viable option
sure you might be able to hit some nice
shots when you swing a corner and
headshot an unsuspecting enemy but it's
not a consistent recipe for success in
the long run playing on high ping is
only going to hurt your win rate well
who knows hopefully one day every player
will be able to play without having to
worry about latency but until that day
comes and until every game has the
infrastructure to provide ultra low
latency then the ping
absolutely matters
aren't any servers near toronto let
alone in canada at all i just realized i
almost said toronto like what the f
my tendency to enunciate every word in
my shoots almost caused me to say
toronto which is just cursed
absolutely cursed
jesus like
toronto tell me you're not from toronto
without telling me you're not from
toronto toronto is the only acceptable
way to enunciate that word